for years we've heard professionals Say
Nothing is Stopping You you can use your
phone and shoot a movie what are your
thoughts on shooting a movie with your
phone I think that's a little
disingenuous there's a lot of things
stopping you from making a movie and it
has nothing to do with the phone it has
nothing to do with the the technology
that's involved um sure you can use a
phone and and you can make a feature
film you can make a short film you can
make a commercial I don't think that's
really the point I think the point for
filmmakers out there is to have a point
of view and some intention and want to
make an emotional attachment or
emotional connection with the the
audience there's so many people out
there taking their phone and dragging it
through a puddle and saying I'm a
filmmaker I think there's some some
problems with the terminology the
vernacular of being a filmmaker because
it's almost meaningless these days
anyone who does anything with a camera
can can be a filmmaker and I suppose
that's a good and maybe a bad thing but
I think you need to use a few more words
to really describe what it is that
you're doing and if we're talking about
films if we're talking about narrative
or documentary and you want to have that
emotional connection with an audience
it's never been the technology although
in the past it it in the past I think it
really was in the past I think if you go
back to the era of film it was a massive
massive burden but we've passed
surpassed that burden right now with
adequate technology at least 10 years so
if if you have come up in the last 10
years at all the technology exists even
a phone could could be acceptable but
yeah I would say that the phone has
never really been the the thing that was
stopping or helping someone to get it
done what arguments do you have for not
using an iPhone to shoot a
movie
uh I've got several but I guess the the
M uh the main argument for not using a
phone for production is that you want to
have appropriate control and you really
do want to be specific about what it is
that you're doing if you just want to
get it done sure the camera that you
have with you might be in your pocket
and that might be the easiest thing and
I believe that if you're doing sort of a
hidden camera sort of verite maybe a
phone makes a lot of sense because you
can kind of get away with it in public
more than you can with another type of
camera however as soon as you move into
appropriate technology and I would say
appropriate technology for the job that
you're doing the task at hand and Cinema
is a very specific task and you can make
all kinds of equipment work for Cinema
but there's a reason why Hollywood
doesn't actually really use phones in
fact that there's a reason why Hollywood
doesn't even use a lot of really
inexpensive smaller cameras for what
they're doing is because the appropriate
technology is designed around a film
crew it's designed around moving as fast
as you possibly can giving you maximum
flexibility and maximum control other
technology have limitations and it may
not be limitations in the way they
perform but could definitely be
limitations in the way that they're used
so you need to be able to use the camera
equipment the camera equipment and all
the equipment in the appropriate way to
get the best results that doesn't mean
that you can't learn and adapt to other
technology and get incredible results
I've been a proponent of this for
decades but um yeah it's it's really
it's really about how you use what you
have and you use the most appropriate
tool that you can for what it is that
you're doing and and uh sometimes that
is very small equip very small types of
cameras or maybe even a phone but for
Hollywood and for major Productions
that's almost never the best choice we
recently heard about a YouTuber who used
an iPad to film um because a larger
screen should we be hearing about more
filmmakers using
iPads I don't think so
um if you if you want me to to follow up
on that I I think that the iPad is a
fine tool it's you know could that same
filmmaker have spent the same amount of
money maybe on used equipment and
actually gotten a better result I would
say yes especially if it was an iPad Pro
or very very expensive iPad that same
infrastructure that went into that iPad
could have been redistributed to
appropriate equipment and I'm guessing
they would have had better results has
hot rod cameras ever sold iPhones or any
types of phones hot red cameras does not
sell um phones I don't think that phones
are the future of the industry I know
that there are some large electronics
manufacturers out there who want to
convince everyone that that is the
future I think it makes for some lovely
commercials but I really don't see the
industry rushing to phones as a way
to make I'm going to use the c-word uh
oh okay
content I don't I know it's sorry
content is is uh maybe
perhaps the you know the worst catchall
term out there but I don't see Hollywood
trying to make future films turn into
content certainly in their production by
introducing content style tools like
phones I think that really what
Hollywood wants to do is use the
appropriate equipment for the job by
evidence of almost everything that is
made these days and for the last 100
years how does a filmmaker uh get their
phone ready to make a movie if they have
an iPhone what would be some maybe lens
adapters different things God I'm I'm
I'm not the best person to to no I'm I'm
going to answer this question no but I'm
not I'm not the best person to advocate
for uh adding equipment to phones I
actually don't think that you derive a
lot of benefit from the look and I know
people out there love their phone and
they want to be able to use their phone
for technology and if that's all all you
have great I I I encourage you to
explore and to create absolutely however
the amount of money that you're
investing in a product that was in in a
device that was never designed to give
you the results that you were you want
to have and just happens to give a
pretty good image means that you're
always going to be fighting against it
means that the interface and how that
you work with it is always going to be
your enemy whereas if you invested a
small amount of money even in something
older and something that is used you
could be uh miles ahead with the at the
end of the day with your final product
any other tips for filming with an
iPhone so if you are going to use your
phone to try to make something I think
it's really important
that you first understand how to see and
by talking about how to see I mean
really understand what it is that you
are shooting and what it looks like your
composition and the lighting and I think
a phone is a great tool for that
especially especially if you're actually
using it to prev visualize what you're
going to do so I think that the best
aspect of a phone is that it gives you
instant access to be able to understand
more or less what it is that you're
going to do with almost no
effort the other thing I would say is
try to learn as much as possible how to
turn off any automatic functions if you
can turn off the automatic functions of
your device it gives you a fighting
chance to control your your dynamic
range your your brightest white and your
darkest Shadow and that's going to make
a huge difference uh audio is of course
a big concern too if you are going to
try to record audio onto your device
there are some fairly inexpensive tools
out there that you can use but you might
actually consider also recording your
audio separately and then marrying your
audio and picture together and post you
can probably get a better experience
just because you don't have extra weird
things hanging off of your
phone